what are you doing you working on new
stand-up like where do you go the first
thing i'm doing which i thought would
really be the first topic for you howard
is i am a series regular on the l word
are you yes oh my wife loves that show
oh that's a good show
oh my god i did it last season i did a
couple episodes and then they said would
you come back we want to make you a
season regular so after we wrapped
gigolo i started and i have about three
more weeks of work on the l word and
possibly howard a sex scene
will you do will you be comfortable no
a nude scene with another woman well
they said it's a sex scene and i told
them when i took the job i'm not doing a
sex scene but the women who were there
are so smart and they're young they're
in their 30s and 40s and they're writing
listen unbelievably great stuff why not
do one of these love scenes with one of
these gorgeous actresses and uh you know
what i mean you say oh stop it listen
i'm blushing you can't see it so good
but i'm blushing you
you must fantasize a little bit that
you'll be on set in walks a very nude
woman who is very fit very very famous
yes i mean everything
and there you are lying there with who
knows what the [ __ ] happens i mean i'm
excited about this for you well kate
medic who plays shane she's directing
that episode so we had a couple talks
and i was like listen she's like don't
worry there'll be an intimacy
coordinator and don't worry but you know
the me is totally panicked about it it's
three weeks away and i'm already like
sweaty are you uh ready to disrobe or is
that a big issue
yeah that's a big issue could see you in
a chemise yeah you know something uh
you